good afternoon
this beautiful afternoon next week
i'll be leaning out the path ahead to
continue our fight against coven 19
to get us to july 4th
this our target date to get life in
america closer to normal
and began to celebrate our independence
from the virus
together with our friends and our loved
ones as we celebrate independence day
but before that i wanted to speak
briefly to all of you today about the
recent
change announced by the center for
disease control and prevention
cdc let me uh say first
while we still have a long way to go in
this fight
and a lot of work to do in may and june
to get us to july 4th
we've made stunning progress because of
all of you
the american people cases and deaths are
down
down dramatically from where they were
when i took office in january 20th
and continuing to fall this is
particularly true
for a group of americans that we were
most worried about
when it came to the virus senior
citizens when i took office in january
we're losing literally tens of thousands
of our seniors
each week grandparents who were loved so
dearly
moms and dads pillars of every community
gone by the thousands every day
at that time less than one percent
of seniors were fully vaccinated when i
took office
today in less than 100 days
more than 67 percent two-thirds of our
seniors
are now fully vaccinated and more than
80 percent of our seniors have had at
least one shot
that effort resulted in a drop of 80
percent
in deaths among american seniors
a 70 drop in hospitalizations
so instead of losing thousands of
seniors
each day we're saving thousands of lives
and more and more as each day goes by
and by the way based on reported data
the proportion the proportion of seniors
who've been vaccinated
is essentially equal between white
and seniors of color i said from the
beginning
that we were going to fight this virus
with equity
equity for all as a matter of fact if
i'm not mistaken
there are more latinos and
african-american seniors
that have been vaccinated as a
percentage than white seniors
these numbers are a sign of progress on
that front as well
now last week i announced that we had
crossed the threshold
of 200 million shots we've now
since inauguration day we have
given 215 million
shots and that anyone 16 years of age or
older
is now eligible to get the vaccine now
today
immediately and because of the
extraordinary progress we've made in
fighting this virus
and the progress our scientists have
made in learning about
how it gets transmitted earlier today
the cdc made an important announcement
starting today if you're fully
vaccinated
and you're outdoors you need and not in
a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask i want
to be absolutely clear
if you're in a crowd like a stadium or
at a conference
or a concert you still
need to wear a mask even if you're
outside
but beginning today gathering of the
group of friends
in a park going for a picnic
as long as you are vaccinated and
outdoors you can do it without a mask
the cdc is able to make this
announcement
because our scientists are convinced by
the data
that the odds of getting or giving the
virus to others
is very very low if you're both been
fully vaccinated
and out the open air the cdc
also clarify which outdoor activities
are safer
or less safe depending on whether you've
been vaccinated
the bottom line is clear if you're
vaccinated
you can do more things more safely
both outdoors as well as indoors
for so for those who haven't gotten
their vaccination yet
especially if you're younger or think
you don't need it
this is another great reason to go get
vaccinated
now now yes
the vaccines are about saving your life
but also the lives of the people around
you
but they're also about helping to get us
get back to closer to normal in our
living
more normal living getting together with
friends
going to the park for a picnic without
needing to mask
up we're back to that place now as long
as you get
vaccinated so go get the shot
it's never been easier and once you're
fully vaccinated
you can go without a mask when you're
outside
and away from big crowds i want to thank
the
team at the cdc for everything they're
doing to help us
lead with science and bring our
communities out of this crisis safely
and responsibly
i also want to thank everyone who's
gotten the vaccine
for doing your patriotic duty and
helping us get
on the path to independence day which
i'll be discussing more in detail next
week
in the meantime i urge all americans
don't let up now keep following the
guidance
go get your vaccination now
it's free and it's convenient
90 of the american people live within
five miles of a site where you can get a
vaccination
you can do this and we will do this
thank you all and god bless you and as
much as the temptation is to stay
outdoors in this beautiful day
i've got more work to do thank you all
very very much mr president if the risk
is so low outdoors why doesn't it apply
to everybody
would you have any preconditions before
meeting with vladimir putin
i uh one at a time
if the risk is so low outdoors why
doesn't this new guidance apply to
everybody
because the science indicates that the
most certain way to make sure it doesn't
spread of both people
have been vaccinated the people you're
with and you're outside
and you chose to wear a mask sir you
chose to wear a mask you chose to wear a
mask as you walked out here
what message were you sending by wearing
a mask outside alone i'm watching me
take it off and not put it back on till
i get inside
do you have any preconditions before
meeting with vladimir putin
i'll discuss that all another day thank
you
will you make it faster to get for them
to get the vaccine the vaccines we will
get soon
india they're suffering what do you say
i'm sorry i'm gonna just the last
question i'll take and i said i'm really
gonna be in trouble
with regard to india i spoke at length
with modi
prime minister we are sending
immediately
a whole series of help that he needs
including providing for those
rendez-severe and other drugs that are
able to deal with this and prevent in
some cases but
recover help recovery secondly
we are sending the actual
mechanical parts that are needed for the
machinery they have to
build a vaccine and that's being done as
well
we're also discussing i've discussed
with him
when we'll be able to send actual
vaccines
to india which would be my intention to
do
the problem is right now we have to make
sure we have other vaccines like
noblevacs and others coming on probably
and i think we'll be in a position to be
able to share
to share vaccines as well as know-how
with other countries who are in real
need
that's the hope and expectation and i
might add
when we were in a bind at the very
beginning india helped us
thank you what did you ask the vice
president to do to help with facts and
skepticism how do you convince those
still hesitant
thanks mr president
he's waiting for us